[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois dans cette
émission l'historien david chanteranne
et le journaliste jean françois coulon
des arts pour napoléon
les derniers témoins racontent aux
éditions du rocher est une anthologie
des récits qui ont été faits par ceux
amis ou ennemis qui était avec napoléon
à sainte-hélène ensuite au jour le jour
l'empereur prisonniers qui ressasse sa
légende
en attendant la mort mais commençons par
une image celle que vous avez choisie
pour illustrer ce début de xxième siècle
cette image
la voici c'est l'ong hood selon les cdc
selon good c'est la maison de napoléon à
sainte-hélène telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui absolument elle diffère de
très peu d'ailleurs avec la façon dont
elle était sous napoléon
grâce au travail du consul de france le
consulat à vis de sainte hélène michel
dancoisne martineau qui passent beaucoup
d'énergie à restaurer cette maison on
voit en effet à un drapeau français
c'est chez nous la barre david
chanteranne oui c'est ça c'est chez nous
maintenant depuis le second empire
c'est un bâtiment qui a été en fait
acheter par napoléon iii il a acheté à
la fois le bâtiment mais également les
briards qui était le premier logement de
napoléon à sainte-hélène et puis surtout
aussi le tombeau ce fameux tombeau où
napoléon va être enterré pendant 19 ans
avant que ce qu'on appelle les cendres
de manière plus générale ne rentre en
france en 1840 et bien commençons
[Musique]
napoléon à 46 ans quand il arrive à
sainte hélène le 14 octobre 1815 et 51
ans quand il y meurt le 5 mai 1821 il
reste donc cinq ans et demi et dans
votre livre on le suit au jour le jour
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez découvert
en sélectionnant tous ces témoignages et
et en vous rendant sur les lieux
david alors anraf en sélectionnant les
différents témoignages on se rend compte
que ce n'est pas tout à fait ce qu'on en
avait appris habituellement c'est à dire
que en regardant exactement ce qui s'y
passe jour après jour tout d'abord on
voit que napoléon on s'imagine quasiment
pendant les premiers mois à repartir
très vite et donc il se dit que ça va
être uniquement un séjour temporaire
donc il se prépare un retour soit en
europe soit aux états unis ce qui était
d'ailleurs sa première idée et puis
finalement et finalement les choses sont
venues mans et surtout après l'arrivée
de ce lot le fameux gouverneur de l'île
de sainte hélène 2 816 jusqu'à la fin eh
bien les animosités vont se révéler et
c'est ça qu'on a voulu montrer avec ces
termes ces témoignages c'est à dire des
éléments qui rappellent comment au
quotidien les choses s'enveniment
et comment napoléon essaie de tirer
encore les ficelles pour écrire ce qui
va devenir ensuite sa fameuse légende
cette légende qui va ensuite aspirer
l'ensemble des écrivains tout au long du
xixème siècle jean françois coulon oui
david a raison il a sculpté sa légende à
sainte hélène il dictait ses campagnes
et les souvenirs revenaient et il savait
très bien qu'il allait être attaqué
d'ailleurs il a été attaqué du temps où
il était à sainte hélène et il a voulu
que à voir aussi la mamie sur sa
postérité et ma foi force est de
constater qu'il y a plutôt bien réussi
parce qu'attention il parle de ses
succès mais aussi des échecs ils parlent
ils parviendront d'espagne il parle bien
du là aussi waterloo l'incompréhensible
journée il n'a jamais compris waterloo
donc tout ça et il sait qu'il va être
attaqué et il se défend déjà et le
plaidoyer est absolument formidable ça à
travers tous ces témoignages
finalement c'est un nouveau portrait de
napoléon qui apparaît alors comment sont
justement par deux
figures féminines qui sont peu connus en
font même si on a beaucoup glosé sur
l'une et l'autre la première c'est betty
balcombe qu'il que napoléon rencontre
alors qu'elle a 13 ans elle vit à sainte
hélène et elle va en partir alors
qu'elle aura 16 ans et on ya dans votre
livre plusieurs témoignages de betty
balcombe qui a écrit par la suite sur
napoléon qu'il avait évidemment
considérablement frappé elle en a peur
au départ et elle le trouve fascinant et
elle le décrit d'ailleurs avec les dents
noires
elle dit que c'est sa vie à lui vient de
son habitude de dessus c'est du sud de
réglisse on n'imagine pas napoléon avec
les dents noires alors dont là on
n'imagine pas du tout et d'ailleurs
c'est pour cette raison que toute cette
cette imagerie populaire de napoléon ce
livre permet justement de faim de
découvrir un autre personnage
c'est vrai que vous l'avez vous avez
raison frédéric habituellement betsy
balcon m'avait appris que napoléon
c'était le record c'est un personnage
odieux détestable avec les femmes
ce qu'on continue de répéter
inlassablement et aujourd'hui chez tous
les détracteurs
en fait il s'avère que c'est un
personnage beaucoup plus doux que ce
qu'il a voulu montrer et betsy va être
charmé par le personnage elle est très
jeune et avec son espièglerie et ce
caractère un petit peu spontané qu'elle
a et bien et va lui donner un séjour au
briard donc c'est le premier séjour
qu'ils passent pendant quelques semaines
dans le dans le domaine de son père
william balcon qui est en fait le
directeur de la compagnie générale des
impôts parce que l'île de sainte-hélène
n'appartient pas à l'angleterre mais la
compagnie générale des indes et donc
betty va apprendre à découvrir ce
personnage qui est à mille lieues de ce
qu'on a pu apprendre donc c'est vraiment
avec ces témoignages à elle un élément
fondamental de la manière dont en
appelons à la fois bien sûr redécouvre
même lui-même
et puis surtout ce se montre à ses
habitants de sainte hélène qui sont très
surpris ll célèbre sa bonté son
amabilité son espièglerie n'arrête pas
de jouer de lui faire des farces raconte
que son petit frère l'appel boni c'est
la prénationale abréviation de bonaparte
en anglais on a aussi imaginé qu'il
avait pu avoir une histoire d'amour avec
avec betty bellecombe
jean-françois trop de trop de
sensationnalisme nom du oui non non non
il n'a pas eu d'histoire avec betty
balcombe il a une histoire avec une
autre femme de la colonie française
à sainte hélène albine mais pas avec
betsy mainetti était david hâle a très
bien et très espiègle c'était un peu
pour appeler à une cure de jouvence
il n'ya que betsy qui pouvaient lui
décrocher sa croix légion d'honneur de
partir avec en cours dans le jardin et
napoléon lui lui offert mais lui a
enfermé une fois une de ses robes elle
allait à son premier bal et ils avaient
entre guillemets subtilisé l'arop donc
c'était un jeu entre les deux et c'est
être ai je crois que c'était très gai en
tout cas pour napoléon ça me fait
beaucoup de bien
alors l'autre vous l'avez dit c'est
albine de montholon alors albine de bons
taux longs on va voir il ya toute une
littérature autour d'elle là c'est elle
qu'on on l'a représenté mais mais on va
voir des livres c'est le dernier amour
de napoléon c'est la maîtresse de
napoléon à sainte-hélène albine de
montholon c'est la femme du général
motos long elle elle quitte enfin du
moins elle quitte pas son mari mais elle
accompagne l'enfant avec son mari alors
qu'elle est déjà enceinte et elle va
accoucher d'une d'une petite fille
qu'elle va prénommé napoléone est-ce
qu'on est véritablement sur quelle était
la maîtresse de napoléon à sainte-hélène
david chanteranne alors non seulement on
en est sûr parce que en fait c'est tout
ça c'est un jeu aussi à la fois
diplomatique et puis de de subtilité de
rapprochement d'intimité entre montholon
le général et napoléon parce que mon
taux l'on veut jouer sa carte est l'une
des cartes maîtresses qui la rend dans
son jeu c'est celui de son épouse il
vous imaginez que napoléon est isolé non
seulement bien sûr de sape de ses
proches qui n'ont pas pu l'accompagner
de sa femme marie louise de sa soeur
pauline de sa mère donc les preuves et
les proches féminin si l'on peut dire
sont très rares et donc albine par son
caractère en revanche à la différence de
betsy son caractère un peu grande dame
qui sait aussi jouer de ses charmes et
bien forcément napoléon va en faire sa
maîtresse et d'ailleurs ils vont en
avoir une petite fille une petite cette
fois-ci joséphine qui naîtra en 1800
8 et c'est à ce titre qu on est certain
que par le prénom qui lui a donné que le
père voilà putatif lui a donné et puis
la façon dont ensuite montholon va se
comporter
eh bien on est sûr que napoléon et
albine ont eu une liaison
d'ailleurs ça va si mal se passer que
par la suite les choses vont un peu mal
tourné albine va délaisser napoléon et
va s'enticher d'un jeune lieutenant un
certain jackson et naples on va la
renvoyer en europe où elle partira avec
ses enfants et le fameux jackson qui
suit pour vous voyez tout ça est tout à
fait plausible non seulement posé mais
où surtout avérée par l'histoire
et qu'est ce qu'elle est devenue
joséphine et vous savez jean-françois
prob et vous savez alors à albine vous
savez qu'on peut voir albine aujourd'hui
toujours parce que albine figurez-vous
était momifié aller dans un cercueil
comme tout à chacun avec une plaque de
verre à la chapelle des pénitents bleus
à montpellier dans la crypte et ces
tunnels et c'est une dame d'une
soixantaine d'années qu'on reconnaît
parfaitement à l'état bill robes
d'époque etc
cet avis de montholon mais qu'est devenu
joséphine la fille d'albine et de
napoléon c'est en tant que c'est bien la
fille dessus de 2,2 de napoléon alors
joséphine je crois que mon camarade et
plus calés sur la vie de joséphine que
moi david oui en fait les enfants des
montots l'on va avoir une triste
destinée
sauf une effectivement joséphine qui va
avoir comme une jolie fille puis alors
bien sûr il ya encore des descendants
des manteaux longs il faut quand même
aussi en parler et des descendants des
manteaux longs notamment françois
françois de de condé montholon café des
des ouvrages vous en avez cité
quelques-uns
et puis ce personnage général du couple
parce que certains couples et était un
personnage à la fois très unie de
montholon et de sa femme et bien va
beaucoup vrai aussi pour le pour la
description et la façon dont napoléon va
être ensuite représenté et montholon va
être si proche de napoléon que il va
prendre la première place au détriment
du grand maréchal bertrand dont on va
peut-être parler qui était le grand
maréchal du palais et donc moto l'ont
finalement c'est lui qui va devenir
légataire testamentaire de napoléon ce
qui va beaucoup heurté les autres
personnages qui entourent cette cour est
donc montholon c'est lui qui va
finalement tiré les ficelles en
particulier grâce à sa femme on
reparlera de ces personnages là mais il
faut bien se réaliser on le voit bien
quand on lit tous leurs témoignages qui
figure dans votre vive l'empereur est
prisonnier il est prisonnier et au bout
de deux mois et demi il s'installe donc
à l'ong hood dont vous nous avez montré
une photo mais quand on voit des photos
de longwood nature l'impression que
c'est petit quand on voit la gravure
qu'on va regarder maintenant on
s'aperçut accepté beaucoup plus grand
que ce à quoi ses sabots de ces salons
good sais c'est pas un petit château
d'en face et c c'est quand même assez
grands noms alors françois annoncé ces
lois c'est loin d'être un c'est loin
d'être un petit château si vous voulez à
l'époque actuelle c'est une très très
jolie maison de campagne pour nous mais
pour cet homme qui a été habitué à vie
dans tous les palets d'europe
il avait 44 palais en europe l'ong hood
c'est très très très petit et il ya
beaucoup de bons ballons goudé donc il
ya une vraie pour miss cuite et on
s'entasse dans les chambres las cases
vides dans un grenier une soupente avec
son fils est une paillasse parce que on
peut même pas se tenir debout tellement
le thouars ont tous le toit sinon c'est
les conditions de vie sont quand même
assez compliqué la preuve c'est que les
anglais voulaient construire un nouveau
look good et ils ont commencé à le faire
d'ailleurs
il avait demandé à l'empereur ou
voulait-il que cette maison soit
construite dans l'île ils en voulaient
pas bref tout ça tu as été un jeu aussi
diplomatiques entre le bourreau est
prisonnier où le prisonnier il bourreau
mais l'ong hood c'était c'était une
petite chose à l'époque alors prisonnier
garder ça veut dire qu'il ya des gardes
autour quoi un david aliaoui à des
milliers d'anglais yard bandes et des
gardes
oui et donc ce sont des ce sont des
régiments qui ce qui se relaie alors des
régiments qui au départ ne sont là que
pour surveiller mais enfin il faut
imaginer qu'à 600 canon tout autour de
l'île donc à moins d'être un très bon
nageur et de le faire de nuit en autant
dire que c'est impossible donc napoléon
espère en revanche que certains
certains généraux installés notamment au
brésil comme google docs un général
hollandais ou d'autres qui sont
installés au texas à proximité
d'ailleurs aux états unis où je trouvais
le frère de napoléon joseph et bien que
ces différents partisans puissent
envoyer des escadres et peut-être même
même parce que ça existait déjà à
l'époque
peut-être même des sous marins alors
tout ça relève un peu la fantasmagorie
mais chez napoléon il ya toujours l'idée
comme un joueur de poker que le coup
d'après peut-être vainqueur donc ici
installe ici installe et il est
surveillé par ces anglais donc plus les
tentatives vont être avéré plus la
surveillance va être accrue et surtout
napoléon va se retrouver dans une anse
quillan pour penser au départ être
uniquement une prison insulaires mais
qui progressivement va se réduire comme
peau de chagrin et donc ses promenades
qu'il aime et en fer à cheval est bien à
la fin et ne seront quasiment plus que
des rêves et il se contentera de
quelques promenades autour
ce qui va aussi beaucoup contribué à la
fois la perte de son oral et puis
surtout à la perte de sa santé alors il
ya le personnage jerry lewis
jean-françois l'île de sainte hélène
oui je me permets de chez les précisions
il ya le sainte hélène est très
importante puisque tous les bateaux qui
descendent d'europe qui vont aux indes
s'arrête à sainte hélène le canal de 16
n'existe pas donc il faut faire des
pleins de nourriture des pleins d'eau
etc
donc il ya toujours beaucoup de navires
qui sont à l'ancré à sainte hélène et
deux corvettes anglaise qui tourne h24
tellement hudson lowe a peur que son
sont prisonniers s'échappent
oui et donc il ya beaucoup de nouvelles
qui arrivent alors avec un sacre est en
décalage
il faut à peu près deux mois et demi je
crois un pour venir d'angleterre sainte
hélène
mais il ya toujours des nouvelles qui
arrivent d'europe et on voit bien quand
on lit les
les témoignages de chacun à quel point
il est il est affamé d'avoir des
nouvelles napoléon alors oui il est
affamé d'avoir des nouvelles
et c'est surtout à partir d'une des
nouvelles les plus importantes
c'est-à-dire le sort qui va lui être
réservé par le fameux congrès d'aix la
chapelle que là il apprend que tous les
espoirs qu'il avait qui l'avait mis dans
certains des personnages qui est encore
au pouvoir en europe et bien ccc rêve
s'effondre et à ce moment là
effectivement à la fois dans le moral
dans les relations qu'il entretient avec
les personnes qui l'entourent pour
naples ont les choses sont totalement
différentes donc on est là à partir de
1818 et c'est pour cette raison qu'une
grande partie aussi des gens qui
l'entouraient très importants comme le
général gourgaud qui est l autre
comparse de montholon avec lequel
d'ailleurs ils ne s'entendent pas très
bien et bien gouffre par aussi en france
donc à ce moment-là napoléon se dit ça y
est cette prison sera mon sera mon ton
beau et il se prépare justement à
l'inéluctable mais arrivera à derniers
événements en 1819 c'est parce que la
famille bonaparte apprenant jeu
justement cette nouvelle où les angles
les anglais les autrichiens les
prussiens les les russes et aussi les
français se sont mis d'accord justement
pour le garder prisonniers là-bas et
bien la famille bonaparte envoie en voie
pour compenser un peu ces événements en
voit ce qu'on appelle une petite
caravane c'est à dire sur tout et bien
maître d'hôtel des personnes qui
s'occupent en tant que domestiques mais
aussi trois personnages très important 2
ab vignali et bonavita qui sont des
corses
et puis un troisième course et en
l'occurrence à un corps très important
encore ce qui est chirurgien et qui va
lui servir de médecin parce que son
médecin personnel vient d'être licencié
par oslo il était irlandais et comité
pour le trouvera du napoléon et bien
haute saône la vie rires donc de là bas
donc il fallait un dernier un dernier
médecin naples ont refusé tous les
autres donc il a fallu envoyer un
médecin et ce médecin il est corse et
savoir beaucoup d' influence pour la fin
de cet épisode de sainte hélène
alors une seule l'eau justement donc le
joaillier de napoléon c'est comme ça que
on l'a l'histoire à la retenue
une chaîne low méprisait même dans son
propre pays
on va le voir d'ailleurs parmi lui aussi
vous faites figurer son témoignage un
tout ce qu'il a pu dire au fur et à
mesure sur l'empereur il a l'impression
au départ quand on le lit
oui que ce serait son physique
repoussant qui aurait offert
immédiatement empêcher l'empereur
d'avoir une bonne relation avec lui
comment voit-il napoléon hudson lowe
quand vous le quand vous leur canton le
relier aujourd'hui ce lot un de nos voix
napoléon comme un prisonnier et je
dirais même plus comme sont prisonniers
voilà il a été nommé là parlent les
anglais parlerait par le régent et le
régent savait pertinemment qu'ils y ne
met pas ce que tu nous la carrière de ce
nom du carré militaire est quand même
pas brillante
il a toujours commander des traîtres il
s'est fait étriller à naples sur lille
en face de naples dont le nom m'échappe
vous allez mére cette magnifique
il rit capri merci à capri donc dessin
napoléon le sait que c'est un militaire
comment on pourrait dire ça de pacotille
d'un vide seul mot est peut-être un peu
fort non
oui pas de pacotille mais il a dirigé
notamment des corses et sa napoléon lui
en voudra à mort il a dirigé les corses
qui avait choisi l'angleterre au moment
du royaume anglo corse ce qu'ils ont
appelé les corses icahn rogers
effectivement dans l'esprit d'un peu
loin alors là c'est rédhibitoire et
sonova en rajouter mais c'est vrai que
son physique joue beaucoup en sa
défaveur
et ce côté opus repoussant va va
contribuer à accentuer les choses mais
ce qui est intéressant dans le
témoignage de ce lot il ne nie pas
justement ce que lui reprochent
d'ailleurs napoléon sans savoir
d'ailleurs ce qu'il écrit il ne nie pas
il dit je réagis comme on me l'a donnée
donc finalement c'est un soldat
méticuleux mais trop méticuleux parce
qu'ils appliquent les ordres alors qu'il
aurait fallu peut-être justement faire
en sorte que napoléon soit de meilleures
dispositions parce que finalement ce
qu'il faut en retenir de tout ça c'est
ce qui va arriver à la fin lorsque
hudson lowe va rentrer après la mort de
napoléon comme vous le disiez petit
réajustement des derricks il va être
détesté des anglais bien sûr du reste de
l'europe
et alors qu'il a un petit rôle assez
lent lorsqu'il revient en angleterre
croyant qu'il va ensuite être acclamé eh
bien on va le bannir et on va considérer
que c'est lui le bouc émissaire et que
toute la haine accumulée contre
contre ces anglais c'est à lui seul
qu'on l'attribué parce que il a été le
geôlier le bourreau vraiment de napoléon
à sainte-hélène
oui il se conduit véritable essaim
napoléon lors de leur entretien lui
avait prédit avec jude law le peuple
anglais vous rejettera vous serez rösti
aux bandes l'histoire d'apple on avait
tous prédit et c'est arrivé
oui c'est conduit vraiment comme un
garde chiourme corps on voit bien que
c'est un certain type mesquin il est au
delà de la mesquinerie où la mesquinerie
conjuguée à la bêtise
conjugué au manque d'humanité une seule
l'eau dans les pages qu'on cite dans le
livre c'est extraordinaire parce que il
dit j'ai fait ça j'ai fait ça à napoléon
et c'est ce qu'il fallait faire
aucun regret rien j'aurais peut-être
même dû en faire plus c'est comme sur
réaliste
aucune introspection parce que ce sont
des mémoires qu'il a écrit pas sur le
moment qu'il écrit plus tard aucune
introspection rien en même temps on est
frappé par le fait que napoléon est
relativement bien traitée pour un ennemi
de cet acabit
il est mieux traité qu'on a traité les
prisonniers ensuite au 20e siècle les
conditions de détention de napoléon sont
très enviable par rapport à celles
qu'ont pu connaître
je sais pas alors je parle pas des
grands bourreaux nazis mais un mais
albert père par exemple
albert speer il est vingt ans d'horizon
dans des conditions plus dures que
celles de napoléon ya pas la haine qu'on
peut avoir
au 20ème siècle pour ses adversaires je
crois que napoléon faisait peur faisait
peur aux anglais bien entendu aux russes
aux autrichiens aux prussiens bien sûr
est que faire d'un pôle et ont donc ça
déjà à lille dead savait pas bien marché
en tout cas leur point de vue sainte
hélène il était plus sur naples on
faisait peur même un dhimmi club de
paris il fait encore peur
donc il a été bien traité il a quand
même dû vendre son argenterie
il a dû il avait fondé en argentine il a
vendu parce que hudson lowe était
tellement
méprisant qui ne donnait pas assez on va
dire assez de nourriture à langon parce
qu'il fallait nourrir quand même
plusieurs dizaines de personnes tous les
jours donc napoléon alors ces politiques
bien entendu il sait très bien qu'en
europe il est obligé de vendre son
argenterie pour pouvoir nourrir de la
petite colonie française
j'imaginais le retentissement que ça
peut avoir parce qu'on angleterre
contrairement à ce qu'on croit il y
avait des partisans de napoléon 1er
non pas le régent pas les gens au
pouvoir mais notamment lady hollande qui
est une femme effectivement qui va qui
va accentuer ce côté là et qui va être
justement qui va permettre à l'opinion
publique que anglaise de se rendre
compte que finalement les conditions
comme olivier sont bien sûr meilleur
qu'un prisonnier seul mais mais tout de
même
comme le dit jean-françois très
justement on en a peur pas uniquement
parce que c'est un grand général c'est
aussi d'impôt lyon c'est le représentant
de la révolution française de tous ses
partisans qui sont soulevées en italie
en allemagne en pologne sur tout et même
en russie qui sont soulevées en disant
ça suffit de ces de ses droits d'ancien
régime ça suffit de cette façon dont on
se comporte et d'ailleurs en germe en
mettant en apollon sous cette forme là
et en le gardant prisonniers il va
devenir finalement il le dira lui-même
7,7 et le dira à bertrand il dira
finalement cet exil me m'enlève de ma
peau de tyrans et lire à ma vie était
celle qui finalement d'un christ moderne
et autonome à porter la couronne
d'épinés qui manquait parce que
finalement napoléon c'est le partisan de
ses idées nouvelles
celui qui a porté le code civil et c2 ce
code civil et de ses idées nouvelles
finalement que vont être la révolution
de 1830 dans toute l'europe essaie de
1848 qui va renverser un certain nombre
de deux royaumes en particulier en
autriche avec méthodique donc c'est pas
forcément tous les royaumes qui vont
tomber
mais au moins ça va faire une structure
est naples où en est l'héritier est
dépositaire de l'idée qui va qui va
perpétuer
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on se dit
qu'au fond c'est à sainte hélène où il
va bâtir sa légende et notamment dans la
légende il va se faire passer pour
l'héritier de la révolution et que l'
empire au fond c'était la révolution qui
s'exportait à travers l'europe et est
aujourd'hui on attend ça lui dénier ce
rôle-là en dix ans
non au fond il a rétabli une monarchie
il a rétabli une dynastie
on voit bien d'ailleurs à sainte-hélène
obsédé par le destin de son fils poussé
regrets portent sur le fait qu'il ne
soit pas mort plutôt son fils alors lui
aurait succédé et serait en train de
renier
alors qu'en est il exactement c'est vrai
que à ce moment là pour toutes les
nations européennes
il est la révolution - il n'est pas du
tout un monarque
il est tard il est il incarne la
révolution son fils frédéric aurait
peut-être pas renier tout de suite parce
que il est né en 1811 si les yeux sont
exacts donc il ya 4 5 ans il y aura eu
une régence
alors maintenant est ce que napoléon
c'est la continuité de la révolution la
réponse est oui
la révolution française s'arrête dans
les plaines de waterloo en 1815 il faut
être maintenant après 10 ans 89 99 10
ans où la france est à feu et à sang où
plus rien ne marche
où on s'est étripé dans tous les sens il
ya une couronne dans le ruisseau dit
napoléon je vais ramasser et cette
couronne c'est le peuple qui l'a mis sur
la tête lempire alors personne ne peut
contester ça c'est une prospérité
incroyable pour la france la france est
l'un des pays les plus peuplés d'europe
et 1 5 million d'habitants vous le
rappelez quand même toutes proportions
gardées entre guillemets c'est la chine
de l'europe au niveau du nombre
d'habitants en tout cas les anglais
c'est à près de 13 millions l'italie
n'existe pas l'allemagne telle qu'on la
connaît n'existe pas c'est une mère de
deux petits sets à 1 enfin bref et
napoléon ramasser de couronnes et c'est
le peuple qui lui met sur la tête il
faut jamais oublier ça là bas non ce que
napoléon a fait en quinze ans de pouvoir
c'est absolument phénoménale le code
civil qui a été toilettée depuis 200 ans
d'à peine 30 %
donc c'était quand même bien construit
sur les rapports des gens de la société
etc
la création des lycées la création des
préfectures l'université les
l'école de commerce qu'il a fait c'est
absolument hallucinant absolument les
sinon les français vivent encore
je voulais voir son napoléon je vous
interromps tous les deux ont fait une
pause et justement on va revenir là
dessus parce que c'est l'essentiel de
son temps qu'ils passent à sainte-hélène
c'est justement à penser à ce qu'il a
fait et à ce qu'il n'a pas fait on se
retrouve dans en deux minutes
[Musique]
nous sommes avec david chanteranne et
jean françois coulon des arts qui publie
napoléon les derniers témoins racontent
aux éditions du rocher alors napoléon à
sainte-hélène va on connaît ce tableau
célèbre on le voit entouré de montholon
de deux gourgaud du grand amiral du
grand général pardon bertrand il est en
train de leur dicter ses mémoires
ce sera le mémorial de sainte-hélène qui
paraîtra est-ce qu'il arrange beaucoup
la vérité alors là je pose la question à
l'historien david chanteranne alors ils
arrangent forcément la vérité de toute
façon ce n'est pas une vérité qui est
ont ils disposent
il faut s'imaginer que des points de vue
des archives il ne dispose pas de tous
donc ils se ils essaient de reconstruire
à partir des éléments qu'il a pu voir
lui-même ou dont on a pu lui rapporter
mais il ne dispose pas comme aujourd'hui
nous l'avons de l'ensemble des archives
qui sont considérables à travers toute
l'europe qui permet justement d'avoir
une prévision plus précise donc
forcément dans certains chiffres dans
certains éléments il est un peu un
parfait en revanche en revanche ce dont
il est sûr et ce qui est très important
ce qu'avait dit tout à l'heure
jean-françois c'est que cette révolution
dont il se veut l'héritier alors bien
sûr on peut lui accorder le fait d'avoir
peut-être un peu dévié mais d'un autre
il a permis justement la révolution qui
était inquiété attaquer de toutes sortes
et de toutes parts par les autrichiens
par les anglais surtout qui ont alimenté
et financé l'ensemble des coalitions
contre la france eh bien il a voulu
apporter d'abord une stabilité et
intérieurs et extérieurs religieuse
également avec le concordat avec les
articles organique qui permet d'avoir la
liberté de culte
on oublie trop fréquemment pourtant en
moselle et en alsace ça continue
d'exister comme ça et puis surtout il a
apporté à cette révolution des formes
monarchique des formes et monarchique
qui permettait d'être accepté par tous
et donc d'une certaine manière il
faisait la synthèse entre la france
d'ancien régime de louis xiv et la
france finalement elle était de
robespierre
d'une certaine manière on en est
aujourd'hui aussi les héritiers la vème
république n'a pas fait autre chose qu'à
voir un système un peu présidentielle
mais avec une rotation des chambres
c'est un apollon qu'on le doit à une
monarchie un peu constitutionnel et il
s'était dit que c'était peut-être ça
l'avenir finalement il est attaqué pour
une autre raison
c'est son ambition un peu dévorante mais
ça c'est après 1811 lorsqu'il est devenu
l'époux de mariam marie-louise donc bien
sûr la l'archiduchesse autrichienne mais
restons un instant justement sur un
napoléon et la révolution on lui
reproche aujourd'hui
rétrospectivement d'avoir été un tyran
mais on le lui reprocher d'ailleurs à
l'époque il le dit d'ailleurs un certain
dans les conversations qui sont racontés
dans votre livre
il dit je n'ai pas commis de crime ce
qu'on dit aussi qu'il est un criminel
dit je n'ai pas commis de crime
alors à part à part l'exécution du duc
d'enghien il n'a pas commis de crime un
napoléon à vos yeux tous les deux il n'a
pas commis il n'y a pas de crever de
crime c'est pas aucun crime politique
n'est pas attribué à napoléon
quant au duc d'enghien il l'a dit à
sainte hélène il le dit à las cases si
mes souvenirs sont exacts
s'il fallait le refaire je le referais
il faut se remettre dans le contexte de
l'époque
il est attaqué de toutes parts on a eu
l'attentât la rue saint-nicaise on
essaie de le tuer les réaliser c'est de
le tuer alors effectivement ce pauvre du
d'enghien on va le chercher de l'autre
côté de la frontière on le ramène
il avoue que kiel conspiraient et je
crois que les généraux de napoléon ont
été très vite en besogne
napoléon leur est certainement gracier
le rat taupe le rêve le rêve
certainement gracié mais bon les
fossettes vincennes la nuit boom
terminée mais si c'était à refaire il le
dit c'est un geste politique je leur
ferai et comme par hasard après tout les
attentats se sont calmés il n'y a plus
rien
david chanteranne elle indique aussi que
persécute passer ses opposants napoléon
il vous donner une idée les emprisonnent
paille les éloigne en général
tout à fait il ya 2000 yet been
personnes qui sont mis aux bandes au
bond de lempire tout au long du régime
il faut les comparer aux 150 milles qui
sont qui sont emprisonnés dans les
prisons ou qui sont vraiment exécuté du
temps encore de louis 15 il faut les
comparer aussi aux 120 me de l'exécuter
de les débuts de la révolution n'a
prononcé l'apaisement effectivement le
duc d'enghien c'est un moment important
c'est pour ça qu'ils en parlent
abondamment
c'est pour ça aussi
qui revient sur la faute très grave dans
son esprit de l esclavage ce sont des
éléments sur lesquels il est revue en
l'esclavagé par exemple il l'a fait de
volonté à la fois d'ordre est aussi d'un
point de vue économique parce que
c'était des îles qu'il avait récupéré
des britanniques mais il ne l'a pas fait
d'un point de vue psychologique ni même
ni même de sa volonté première il ne l'a
pas fait par exemple pour l'île maurice
la réunion où les compteurs d un don
qu'il n'est pas né raciste ni
esclavagiste comme on a voulu le
prétendre il a repris une situation qui
était la sienne il l'a maintenue
effectivement c'est le décret qu'il
signe en 1802 et le maintien mais quand
ils arrivent au pouvoir de nouveau en
1815 après les 100 jours il signe son
premier de les traiter au mois de mai
dont la fin de la traite négrière il le
signe est le premier à le faire en
europe et ensuite lorsqu'ils arrivent à
sainte hélène et bien c'est le moment
justement de réfléchir de re re penser à
toutes les oeuvres qu'il a pu commettre
ou des choses positives et finalement ça
sert de laboratoire d'idées sainte
hélène il va dicter à tous les gens qui
sont autour de lui à la fois l'intimité
avec avec marchands et ali qui sont à
ses côtés à la fois effectivement d'un
point de vue militaire avec montholon et
gourgaud et avec bertrand et la ska et
l'aspect politique et cet aspect
politique c'est de montrer qui il a fait
des erreurs mais aussi certains éléments
qu'il a pu tenter dans un premier temps
doivent être maintenus et il faut aller
plus loin et c'est en cela d'ailleurs
que naples en 3 sera un c'est ainsi que
sa soeur véritablement dans l'esprit
alors c'est pour rester sur l' esclavage
parce que c'est véritablement le péché
principale qu'on lui reproche
aujourd'hui en cette année de
bicentenaire de sa mort d'avoir rétabli
l'esclavagé gens c'est vrai il l'a
rétabli il a rétabli aux antilles pour
des raisons strictement économique
à l'époque c'est extrêmement important
le les revenus des senti du sucre
déprendre plantation c'est un peu le
pétrole de l'époque il l'a maintenu dans
les îles qu'on avait prise aux anglais
ou là les esclavages n'avait pas été
abolie donc il l'a maintenue c'est vrai
qu'il est qui le qu'il a regretté il a
il
nice était une erreur une faute oui
alors c'est une faute parce que
lorsqu'il est avec notamment avec l'un
des esclaves à l'île de sainte-hélène
jean-françois l'a rappelé sainte-hélène
étant sur la route des indes
il ya énormément d'esclaves à la fois
mâle est à la fois chinois il ya
beaucoup d'esclaves effectivement sur
l'île est l'un des esclaves qu'ils
rencontrent au tout début de son séjour
qui s'appelle toby et bien ils nous
proposent à toby de le libérer de lui
donner sa liberté et toby lui dit mais
mais mais bonnie parce que c'est comme
ça qu'on l'appelle sur place cyril sait
pas trop comment l'appeler le dit mais
vous savez moi ma vie c'est comme ça ce
serait peut-être trop hâtif de le faire
en revanche il faut que cet esprit
viennent chez les populations et on se
souvient qu'en france il faudra attendre
1848 donc on veut pas l'attribuer
uniquement quand napoléon 7
ce rétablissement il faudra attendre
1848 ce n'est pas des rois ni donc nous
surtout aux loups 18me encore napoléon
iii qui pourtant avait tenté de le faire
qui va le faire après avec beaucoup
d'application
mais il faudra attendre la seconde
république lorsque napoléon iii est
encore président la république pour que
ce soit justement aboli par ce cher mais
il faudra attendre de longues années
pour que dans les faits ça le soit donc
les mentalités ne sont pas encore là il
ya une exploitation des hommes et je
vous rappelle évidemment que l'esclavagé
moderne n'est toujours pas aboli ce à
celui ci parce que dans les fêtes il ya
encore beaucoup d'esclaves et les
milliers au congo comptant dans le monde
donc
napoléon il est revenu sur cet épisode
il a reconnu ses fautes mais il dit on
ne pourra pas jeter les 240 réformes que
j'ai faite uniquement pour waterloo qui
était battu par où j'ai été battu ce
plutôt et surtout l'esclavagé ce qui va
ce qu'on m'attribue tout le temps alors
par rapport au ca réputation de tyrans
là aussi se défend et dit qu'au fond il
a toujours eu l'adhésion du peuple
c'était ça semble très important pour
lui est-ce que ça l'était vraiment quand
il était au pouvoir
est ce que il pas été un tyran quand il
était au pouvoir
la presse était muselée on le sait
l'opposition pouvait être envoyé loin de
paris
elle n'était pas emprisonné n'était pas
persécutés mais elle était quand même
mise à l'écart alors est ce que
véritablement il a eu l'adhésion du
peuple est ce qu il a recherché et
est-ce qu'il la trouvait alors napoléon
et le peuple il faut se remettre dans le
contexte de l'époque
la france est une république dont le
gouvernement a été confiée à un empereur
et napoléon premier a été élu
un peu plus de 3 millions de voix 60000
je crois ont voté contre
si mes souvenirs visuels sont exactes
qu'est ce que voulaient les français ils
voulaient qu'on arrête 10 en guerre
fratricide donc napoléon apporter
l'égalité auquel les français tiennent
beaucoup de toujours maintenant
d'ailleurs et la fraternité
alors vous avez virés lui manque la
liberté la liberté on est dans un pays
où 90 % des gens ne savent pas lire
il va falloir les éduquer d'où la
création des écoles des universités
appelle etc
et d'ailleurs on le voit très bien en
1815 compte y avions pouvoir la
constitution de l'empiré beaucoup plus
libéral parce que les gens ont progressé
est-ce que qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il
fallait faire à sa place on peut son
peut s'interroger se poser la question
david chanteranne oui alors cet aspect
aussi de la popularité on la retrouve
justement comme le dit jean-françois au
moment où justement les questions se
posent entre le choix entre louis xviii
c'est à dire un retour à l'ancien régime
alors avec peut-être des aménagements
mais le retour de napoléon et lorsque
naples on revient au moment des 100
jours lorsqu'ils passent par les alpes
cette fameuse route napoléon
d'aujourd'hui il demande une femme qui
était à proximité qui ne la reconnaît
pas donc il se dit tant mieux je vais
avoir un peu une sorte de sondage direct
il lui demande mais pourquoi la vieille
choisi tube c'est comme ça qu'on
s'appelait pourquoi choisis-tu plus tôt
l'un plutôt que l'autre
finalement l'un et l'autre c'est à peu
près la même chose mais au moins
napoléon c'est un mec du peuple c'est un
homme du peuple c'est celui qu'on a
choisi c'est un homme qui nous ressemble
et en sera finalement il avait plutôt
confiance parce que il avait fait le
parcours justement d école royale
ensuite d'avoir été proche de la
révolution et d'avoir repris les fonds
monarchique finalement ça plaisait au
plus grand nombre parce que c'était cet
aspect qui permettait justement
concilier de france qui était autrefois
opposés
le seul aspect évidemment le plus
discutable et le plus terry
cette ambition dévorante qui va conduire
à la fois en espagne et en russie avec
la conscription qui n'a de dette pas de
napoléon mais d'un peu avant de la
révolution avec la joie la loi jourdan
delbrel eva 7 conscription va envoyer
des dizaines de milliers d'enfants et
d'hommes et de fils en notamment sur les
routes de l'europe et la plupart vont
périr mais quand on dit la plupart il
faut se rendre compte que par rapport à
la population de l'époque ça ne
représente 4 7 et 8%
donc c'est beaucoup moins par exemple
même si on n'aime pas ce genre de
comparaison beaucoup moins que la guerre
14 18 alors c'est effectivement c'est le
bilan des des guerres napoléoniennes là
aussi c'est au détriment de napoléon
c'est quelque chose qu'on lui reproche
beaucoup d'abord parce qu'aujourd'hui la
guerre est très mal vu ce qu'elle
n'était pas à l'époque la comparaison
avec la première guerre mondiale tient
ne tient pas puisque la guerre s'était
considérablement brutalisé l'artillerie
de de la guerre de 14 c'est autre chose
que l'artillerie napoléonienne néanmoins
ace que les guerres napoléoniennes ont
été si si criminel si barbare qu'on le
dit aujourd'hui
ah bon il faut se remettre encore une
fois dans un peu dans le contexte de
l'époque parce que c'est très facile de
juger deux cents ans avant nous avec les
yeux et la culture d'aujourd'hui c'est
très facile et ça peut être aussi très
stupide
il ya eu cette coalition sous l' empire
les anglais payés par les anglais les
autrichiens les russes ne voulait pas du
régime révolutionnaire qu'il a kill kill
en foutait la trouille et ils ont raison
y régnait de droit divin royer divine et
tout d'un coup la france dit on arrête
tout ça et on met un type qu'on est les
sur le trône et c'est donc ça leur
plaisait pas du tout alors manque de pot
le génie militaire de napoléon a fait
que
jusqu en tout cas jusqu'en 1812
maintenant du 112 il a gagné tout c'est
toutes ces batailles avec les russes il
disait la chose suivante je gagne tout
bemba étaient russes mais cela ne
termine rien parce qu'il est peut-être
pas tout à fait compris la notion de
l'âme russe
mais ça c'est notre un autre un autre
débat mais oui après ce combat il
fallait attendre que les ennemis
arrivent sur le sol français ce qu'ils
ont fait en 1815 il s'en sont pas privés
d'ailleurs où il fallait aller les
combattre un appelé ont gagné ses
batailles avec les jambes de ses soldats
il a inventé aussi la guerre moderne
voilà il y avait des différentes armées
c'est en 1804
quand il va en 1805 larmes et à boulogne
on va l'angleterre va nous voir de très
près et la langue l'état commence
vraiment à se faire du souci donc des
autrichiens attaque et napoléon dicte le
fameux plan qui finira à austerlitz
il fait pirouette tc sète torrent commis
17 corps d'armée et c'est la victoire du
mco la reddition d'ulm et cette victoire
absolument splendide d'austerlitz qui
est toujours étudiées dans les écoles de
guerre mais sur commun dix mille autres
russes contre 68 français ce sur le plan
de la tactique qu'il est formidable
napoléon il ya aucun doute il surpasse
tout le monde son époque mais sur le
plan de la stratégie et notamment de la
stratégie à long terme
est ce qu'on peut et est ce que lui même
d'ailleurs quand il est à sainte-hélène
s'interroge rétrospectivement après tout
il a mené pendant tout le temps où il a
été au pouvoir des guerres contre
différents ennemis qui n'était jamais
l'ennemi principal puisque l'ennemi
principal de naples est au c
l'angleterre au rythme là il ne la
feront qu'à trafalgar où il perd et à
waterloo où il perd entre les deux îles
à iris et il s'impose à tout le monde
sauf aux anglais et est au fond on a
l'impression qu'il ne sait pas où il va
ya pas de plan j'ai l'impression que cet
empire dont il rêve
il ne sait pas oui où il s'arrêtera ni
oui comment sera comment est-ce qu'il va
devoir traiter les populations qui
seront sous sa domination
on sait on a l'impression qu'il est de
ta moustache somnambule david
chanteranne au heat et ça tient
ça tient trois choses ça tiendra chose
c'est à dire que l'histoire
effectivement de la révolution et il en
est non seulement l'héritier mais il
doit se retrouver avec une situation
catastrophique à la fois d'un point de
vue économique parce que les caisses
sont vides vous rappeler que le
directoire a été obligé de faire ce
qu'on appelle la banqueroute des deux
tiers ce à dire que si vous avez 100
francs à l'époque dans votre sur votre
sur vos comptes
ça ne représentent plus que 33 francs
c'est à dire que tout est perdu et leurs
paroles c'est quasiment que si on
mettait quasiment les compteurs à zéro
donc il se retrouve à une situation
économique terrible ils se retrouvent
avec les armées étrangères aux portes de
la france et surtout il se dit que et
bien il faut une stratégie à court terme
c'est pour ça qu'on peut lui reprocher
mais à court terme il va faire en quatre
ans sous le consulat
ce que personne n'avait fait jusqu'à
effectivement on l'a dit jusqu'au code
civil
mais effectivement ça manque d'envergure
par la suite pourquoi parce que tout
simplement il doit parer au plus pressé
et c'est pour cette raison qu'à sainte
hélène justement c'est la deuxième
raison à sainte hélène il attend
justement de réfléchir d'avoir une
stratégie au long cours d'avoir une
pensée politique qu'il peut donner à ses
héritiers et aux générations suivantes
c'est pour cette raison qu'il dicte à
l'afp gaz on le voit dans cette dans
cette image qui est derrière vous
frédéric qui dictent alaska dès qu'il
dit à l'ensemble des personnes qui leur
sont autour de lui pour montrer qu'il
était d'un point de vue psychologique
intimiste avec notamment ses domestiques
mais aussi aux généraux et aux
politiciens qui sont que sont surtout
les
les témoins comme las cases où bertrand
en disant voilà les erreurs que j'ai
faites mais surtout que là que l'europe
se rendent compte que les deux grandes
puisque ans qui vont émerger
ça c'est la troisième élément très
important les trois les deux grandes
puissances ce seront les etats-unis qui
sont très nouvelle à l'époque un
indépendance ne date que de 2007 176 et
la russie en dix ans les deux blocs qui
sont là ce quelqu'un le premier à le
dire
et la troisième dans le set troisième
réflexion il ya un élément très
important
on sait que la phrase est un pape au
crif donc là dessus on peut avoir
quelques doutes mais quand même il a
côtoyé les chinois je vous disais dans
dans cette proximité à sainte hélène et
il dira quand la chine s'éveillera le
monde tremblera
ça signifie pas uniquement qu'il a pensé
dans tous ses aspects à la fois
économiques stratégiques mais il a pensé
que justement la puissance à la fois
démographique la puissance d'une
stratégie lui n'a pas d'idéologie
napoléon c'est ça qu'on peut peut-être
aussi le projet mais on peut pas leur
part contre le comparer à des dictateurs
moderne il n'a pas d'idéologie ni
destructrice ni d'idéologie id vraiment
parce que il est à la fois
originaire de la petite noblesse et puis
c'est fait de la révolution donc il n'y
a pas d'idéologie préconçues donc il
fait au fur et à mesure et donc ce
côté-là de prévoir à la fois les deux
blocs et la chine
finalement c'est ça qui va être
apparaître comme la chose la plus
importante et la plus moderne et c'est
pour ça que ce livre permet justement de
révéler des éléments qu'on n'était pas
pu souligner auparavant
jean-françois vous lirez ce qu'il écrit
oui tout à fait ce qu'il écrit sur
l'europe
cette étonnamment moderne il préfigure
l'europe telle qu'on la connaît pas
encore on a de quoi on peut encore
renforcée à renforcer l'europe
la monnaie unique qui dit attendez sur
les sur les monnaies d'argent ou d'or
qu'on me mette la tête d'untel ou untel
je m'en fiche ne joue que ça le même
poids sur la monnaie unique nous a
facilité des changes
il ay là il est extrêmement visionnaire
et surtout il donne des conseils à ses
successeurs dont certains devraient
comment dire devrait vraiment les lire
et les pensées sur la façon de diriger
les peuples et surtout les français oui
c'est vrai qu'il aubin il en donne mais
très important aussi
oui il ya un aspect très important que
pour finir là-dessus et frédéric désolé
le sol le bond très important aussi qui
est révélateur de sa dans son parcours
personnel et de sa volonté
c'est l'éducation vous avez tout à fait
raison quand vous le disiez tout à
l'heure c'est à dire l'université
impériale qui est un peu notre ministère
de l'éducation d'aujourd'hui parce que
ce n'est pas uniquement que l'université
c'est beaucoup plus large
il ya aussi les lycées et puis surtout
que tous les lycéens connaissent c'est
le baccalauréat et ce baccalauréat il
est diffusé à travers toute l'europe
donc ça signifie qu'on a la même chance
d'égalité à la fois en système
d'éducation parce que lui napoléon il
s'en est rendu compte dans son parcours
venus de corse dans cette ajaccio qui ne
compte que trois mille habitants
et il est arrivé vraiment à parvenir à
anne à une puissance aussi importante
par le travail et par l'éducation qu'il
avait reçu à brienne et à paris donc
c'est par l'éducation qui s'est
améliorée qui s'était levé et cette
ascension sociale
eh bien il en est lui-même l'un des
représentants les plus efficaces à
propos de ce bilan
et c'est surtout encore un petit bout
frédéric si vous permettez
et c'est surtout napoléon disait je veux
que chaque soldat est dans sa besace un
bâton de maréchal
c'est tout est basé sur la méritocratie
si c'est pas la république ça faut
m'expliquer à propos de ce bicentenaire
on commémore le 200e anniversaire de la
mort de napoléon
j'ai vécu moi petit le bicentenaire de
sa naissance en 1969 alors est-ce que
c'est mon mon souvenir qui est déformé
j'étais comme tous les petits garçons de
l'époque je suis devenu bonapartiste je
me souviens d'une vraie commémoration en
face à l'impression que napoléon était
partout je me souviens plus en revanche
si si georges pompidou le nouveau
président de la république au moment où
ça commence en août 1969 souvient pas
s'il ya des festivités de l'état du
gouvernement
mais napoléon est partout aujourd'hui il
est beaucoup plus critique et un 51 ans
plus tard on se demande même si l'état
va le commémorer le président de la
république et bagnols macron a dit qu'il
allait le faire donc en mai aux mamans
de l'anniversaire de sa mort enfin on se
souvient qu'en 2005 pour le bicentenaire
de sterlings jacques chirac président de
la république avait refusé de commémorer
austerlitz un scandale alors qu'il avait
envoyée
un porte-avions pour commémorer
trafalgar c'est quand même c'est drôle
et donc on voit bien que on n'est plus
du tout dans la même ambiance en ce qui
concerne napoléon 1
de l'eau a coulé sous les ponts et
surtout notre vision de l'histoire a
changé un david chanteranne oui notre
vision de l'histoire elle a changé et ça
révèle bien justement les maux de notre
société et c'est à dire que on va
prendre un élément particulier sur
lequel d'ailleurs on peut discuter
d'ailleurs l'historien trappe
les historiens travaillent
continuellement là dessus et je ne cesse
de répondre aux questions de vos
confrères
mais du point de vue surtout du bilan
général il faut se représenter aussi
tout le reste il faut pas jeter le bébé
avec l'eau du bain
si l'on peut dire napoléon je vous
disais c'est 240 réforme et cette
histoire et l'ex fondamental ça signifie
quoi tout simplement pour notre société
ça signifie qu'il faudrait mettre quoi
tout tabac c'est ça que cherche aussi
les détracteurs de d'apollon c'est
finalement se servir de nos plans comme
une sorte de bouc émissaire en essayant
de taper sur un personnage qui est mort
évidemment il ya 200 ans et d'une
certaine manière c'est aussi de chercher
à abattre les fondements de la société
parce que d'apollon ces éléments là
justement c'est comme le disait jean
françois la méritocratie le travail le
labeur c'est à dire s'élever par le
travail
et justement l'égalité des chances une
très belle représentation finalement et
qui symbolise tout ça c'est la légion
d'honneur la légion d'honneur à la
différence des ordres précédent qui
était attribué par les rois selon votre
naissance et selon votre proximité à la
cour là la différence légion d'honneur
quelles que soient vos origines quel que
soit votre métier que vous soyez
d'ailleurs laïcs religieux
que vous soyez militaire que vous soyez
scientifique quelles que soient les
éléments déjà à l'époque pas uniquement
aujourd'hui un sportif n'existait pas
mais il ya un sportif aurait pu être
décoré par napoléon ça montre que c'est
une valeur de mérite et une valeur
d'exemple pour la société et ça c'est
tout à fait révélateur c'est pour cette
raison d'ailleurs que les américains les
japonais les chinois les brésiliens va
tout le monde dans le monde révèle aussi
en napoléon et trouvera en apollon ce
caractère là c'est à dire qu'on à
l'égalité des chances qui était tout à
fait nouveau à son époque
jean-françois que l'on des heures alors
de gaulle
disait malraux qui lui faisait remarquer
que napoléon avait laissé la france plus
petit qu'il ne l'avait trouvée et il
avait dit malraux ne marchandent ont pas
la grandeur est effectivement de gaulle
devait théoriquement président et les
fêtes du la naissance de napoléon mais
un référendum en a décidé autrement et
c'est pompidou qui a fait un discours le
le 15 août 69 ajaccio alors après
effectivement nos dirigeants politiques
à l'elysée que ça soit chirac vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure rien pour
austerlitz si c'était une petite prise
d'armes que villepin premier ministre à
l'époque avait fait faire autour la
colonne vendôme ne savait rien dossier
était vide mais chirac est renvoyé le
porte-avions le charles-de-gaulle défilé
pour fêter trafalgar absolument
incompréhensible non peuvent en hollande
sarko on peut se demander si ce napoléon
ne les écrase pas si napoléon ne leur
fait pas peur finalement s'il fait pas
peur à vers le public c'est idiot c'est
lui qui l'a défendu c'est lui qui l'a
porté sur les fonts baptismaux cette
république
alors donc on peut s'interroger peut se
poser des questions l'elysée je l'écris
dans le livre j'ai appelé mois d'octobre
plusieurs fois je vais enlever des mails
pour savoir ce que le prénom macron
avait alain jardin le 5 mai 1808
depardon 2021 on m'a jamais répondu mme
adrienne répond je suis très content oui
il a dit qu'il allait commémorer donc on
peut s'attendre à un discours d'
emmanuel macron qui est qui lui-même est
arrivé au pouvoir très jeune à 39 ans et
demi napoléon c'est à 30 ans à 30 ans
qu'il qu'il a commencé à gouverner la
france et est à 45 ans il perd il est il
est fait prisonnier l'aigle est à 45 ans
donc ça dure quinze ans
ses 15 ans là vous avez l'air de dire
l'un comme l'autre que la france n'a pas
à en rougir
néanmoins qu est ce qui reste
véritablement de napoléon alors vous
l'avez dit le code civil
on lui reproche d'avoir été un peu trop
patriarcal le code civil de napoléon le
code napoléon miam enfants n'en sortira
aujourd'hui david chanteranne oui alors
il est effectivement très patriarcales
par rapport à notre vision contemporaine
mais il faut s'imaginer que par exemple
la femme qui n'avait pas droit du tout
auparavant
là effectivement n'en a pas forcément
autant que ce qu aurait imaginé une
olympe de gouges ou une madame roland
sous la révolution
mais au moins au moment où elle perd son
mari lorsqu'elle devient veuve la femme
dans le code civil et sept indiqué noir
sur blanc la femme devient chef de
famille est là toute la propriété la
pleine propriété de ses biens et surtout
il peut les transmettre à ses enfants ce
qui est là une valeur considérable
alors bien entendu dans ses rapports
effectivement napoléon a pu parfois être
un peu rustre mais ans lorsqu'il était à
sainte hélène je voulais dit tout à
l'heure avec médecine balcombe avec
alvin de montholon mais même avec madame
bertrand qui est une anglaise qui a
épousé son grand maréchal du palais
excusez du peu
eh bien avec madame bertrand il se
montre comme étant un personnage tout à
fait convenable et rappelé rappelez vous
il a quand même comme maire madame
madame laetitia letizia ramolino qui
était quand même une femme non seulement
très joli mais avec un fort caractère et
sait ce que c'est qu'une femme qui a la
volonté donc il a tout à fait compris
qu'une femme était sans vouloir
paraphraser aragon la femme était
l'avenir de l'homme et donc il a voulu
comprendre ça il a avancé effectivement
que le projet par rapport à aujourd'hui
évidemment mais ne faisons pas d'
anachronisme
on a pu lui reprocher cela mais au moins
c'est une avancée majeure et la femme a
des droits et ne disons pas autre chose
parce que quand on parle de napoléon
misogyne c'est qu'on le regarde mais
faisant la comparaison avec les
personnages qui l'entouraient à cette
même époque et notamment les rois de
retour d'un plan est bien en avance sur
leur temps jean-françois si vous voulez
en 2021
les français ne savent peut-être pas
mais qu'ils vivent entre guillemets sous
napoléon alors je suis une petite
antisèches pour pas oublier le conseil
d'état c'est lui le sénat c'est lui la
liberté de culte c'est lui la banque de
france c'est lui
les départements c'est lui
le régime des retraites des
fonctionnaires c'est lui les lycées
c'est lui les grandes écoles c'est lui
la légion d'honneur les chambres de
commerce le franc germinal la cour
d'appel le code civil
l'arc de triomphe l'université la bourse
de paris c'est lui le code du commerce
si lui le cadastre ci lui etc etc etc
on a parfois tendance à l'oublier merci
tous les deux je rappelle le titre du
livre qui vient de paraître napoléon les
derniers témoins racontent aux éditions
du rocher
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]